[Music]
on this wednesday night the tories turn
on their leader aaron o'toole is voted
out by the federal conservative caucus
this country needs a conservative party
that is both an intellectual force
and a governing force who'll take over
and can the fracture in the party be
fixed
patience wears thin with the blockades
disrupting lives in ottawa and alberta
when will the police act you're trying
to say that this is a peaceful protest
it's not very peaceful to me
the u.s bolsters its military presence
in eastern europe waiting for moscow's
next move and the remarkable life and
work of a canadian scientist and
professor i wouldn't be where i am now
if it wasn't for jeff he was a mentor to
new scientists and a fierce defender of
facts
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a big political upheaval
in ottawa aaron o'toole has lost his
grip on the federal conservative party
ousted as leader by a majority of his
own mps who voted him out in a secret
ballot o'toole had pleaded with them to
give him more time but his enemies in
the party have been sharpening their
knives since losing the last election
and today 73 of 119 caucus members
turned against o'toole this was part of
his message after that vote
canada is in a dire moment
of our history
you need only take a walk down the
street in front of parliament to see how
divided we are what canadians deserve
from a conservative party is balance
ideas and inspiration
o'toole had warned the party it must
choose either a negative extreme path or
a more moderate one that will now be up
to the next leader to navigate david
aiken is on top of all the developments
tonight david
well donna in the end it was not close
nearly two-thirds of the 119 mps in air
no tools caucus voted to show him the
door caucus spoke pretty convincingly
and we're going to move on we're going
to find a new leader we needed a new
captain to bring us all together and i
think it was time for a change and
the majority of our grassroots movement
felt that that was needed
it wasn't quick mps debated for three
hours in a virtual closed-door meeting
while protesters honked outside their
parliament hill offices
insiders say o'toole spoke twice he
offered to meet with caucus dissidents
and move a leadership review that had
been scheduled for august 2023 up but it
was to no avail o'toole delivered a
parting statement on facebook here the
other side listen to all voices not just
the echoes from your own tribe
realize that our country is divided
and people are worried
he did not meet reporters wednesday nor
did he attend question period where had
he done so he would have heard his chief
opponent the prime minister pay tribute
to his work there is a lot we don't
agree on for the direction of this
country but he stepped up to serve his
country and i want to thank him uh for
his sacrifice thoughts now turn to
o'toole's replacement i think we have
some incredible great strong people
candace virgin michelle rempel gardner
pierre poliev
uh any other one of those three right
now would be
my picks
is an ontario mp who served in stephen
harper's cabinet he's a conservative fan
favorite we'll see what happens but i i
hope pierre pauliev puts his name
forward and if he does i would support
him one hundred percent the big thing
that we
need unity in our party right now that
means a bit of a bit of a strong hand at
the tiller but insiders say that until
the party's governing national council
sets the rules sets the spending limits
and crucially sets a date it's too early
to speculate who will run
now the immediate order of business is
to pick an interim leader at least three
mps want that job and the tory caucus
meets this evening to sort that one out
donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you
the anger and the blockades in downtown
ottawa and at the u.s canada border in
this in southern alberta have carried on
for another day though in kutz alberta
tonight where protesters have blocked
the road near a busy border crossing for
five days there appears to be some
progress we'll get to that in just a
moment but first to the nation's capital
police say about 250 people remain and
the trucks and the honking and the
intimidation of people continues to
impact essential services and businesses
ottawa police call the situation highly
volatile and say the protesters are
getting funding and organizational help
from american supporters there are lots
of questions about why the city and the
police haven't taken more action to end
the disruption as abigail beamon reports
the trucks and protesters who are still
there say they're digging in for the
long haul
street hockey in front of the supreme
court of canada
dancing santa a couple of anti-semitic
signs
and horn blasts all day long
many who call ottawa home and don't live
in the middle of the road have had
enough these people are uh
taking our freedom away to promote their
own brand of freedom and i don't think
that's fair get rid of them
do you hear it down there that's where i
live
frustrated police won't move in to get
protesters out what i'm seeing is the
blatant hypocrisy in the way that
they're treating a largely white
demonstration versus a black and
indigenous organization i am sorry for
the living hell that you are enduring
during an update from police counselors
across the city expressed concern police
said the situation is now somewhere
between a demonstration and a long-term
effort to occupy the streets all options
are being discussed including military
aid but no specific plan put forward all
such options come with significant risks
risks to rioting
risk to injury and risk to death three
people have been arrested and charged
and police say multiple investigations
are ongoing with more protesters
expected to join this weekend the police
chief wouldn't answer how long this
could last
there may not be a policing solution to
this demonstration he says there is a
significant american component to the
protest and its significant funding the
gofundme campaign has surpassed 10
million dollars
late wednesday it was paused a message
reads it's under review to ensure it
complies with applicable laws
i don't know how long this is going to
last but
try
two years of
losing your job not knowing if you're
going to lose your home 2023 2024 i'm
here for the rate i can't work
i can't work i can't go stateside
police pegged the costs of all this at
three million dollars and growing
compare that to the cost of the entire
canada 150 event on the hill it cost
less than half the price tag here
upwards of eight hundred thousand
dollars a day and that doesn't include
the other impacts to the city and the
economy the rito center for example a
major downtown mall has said it will
stay closed until next week donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa
tonight thanks
there are signs of a breakthrough
tonight in kutz alberta after days of
disruption near the u.s border our
heather urex west is there and joins me
now heather what's happening tonight
donna i can tell you that the situation
here looks a lot different than it did
earlier today protesters have moved
their vehicles to the shoulders opening
up a lane of traffic in both directions
though rcmp say that travel is still not
recommended quite yet still it is a very
hopeful sign here after a very tense few
days
this is what we're trying to get through
oh my god
cell phone video captures the moment of
impact coots resident tara chamber had
just left town to get groceries when she
was hit it was terrifying absolutely
terrifying the crash happened tuesday
afternoon as rcmp moved in to try and
dismantle the illegal blockade at the
coots border crossing
police warned protesters that if they
did not leave peacefully arrests would
follow a few did leave but then we had
a bunch of vehicles and farm machinery
that were to the north at a roadblock
that was set up on highway 4 to the
north those vehicles breached the
roadblock and they did that by
driving at quite high speeds it was one
of those vehicles that hit tara
chamber's car police say her husband was
then assaulted before the driver left
the scene all we were doing was going to
go get groceries
and they're trying to say that this is a
peaceful protest
it's not very peaceful to me on tuesday
alberta's premier urged protesters to
end the blockade while calling for calm
anybody who feels sympathetic
to those engaged in this blockade please
stay away from the area
please do not further intensify an
already difficult situation
the police have a job to do
beyond the rcmp checkpoint several dozen
protest vehicles gathered wednesday
their drivers telling global news
they've come in a show of support for
those still here our intention remains
to
restore movement of goods and vehicles
on the road but
not at the risk of public safety
and rcmp tell me that that group of
protesters beyond the rcmp checkpoint to
the north of here has grown in size so
that is something that rcmp are still
watching very closely right now but
again some hopeful signs as this
blockade
is in its fifth day donna
all right heather europe's west near the
u.s alberta border there are some
significant developments tonight in the
tensions over ukraine britain confirms
it is intercepted and escorted four
russian bomber aircraft that it says
were approaching uk airspace jets were
scrambled from a military airfield in
northern scotland after unidentified
aircraft were spotted the royal air
force says four russian bear aircraft
were intercepted they did not enter uk
airspace
and the us is deploying thousands of
troops to eastern europe on top of the
thousands of soldiers already on standby
in the region washington and moscow are
still in a stalemate over ukraine
there's little sign of a diplomatic path
forward and tonight leaked documents
revealed nato's terms to try to get the
russian president to step back from the
brink of war
jackson prescott reports new satellite
images suggest russia has further
bolstered its military presence near
ukraine
the west is now responding in kind with
an american carrier strike group in the
region and thousands of u.s troops on
route to russia's doorstep it's
important that we send a strong signal
to mr putin and frankly to the world
that nato matters to the united states
it made it matters to our allies the u.s
will redeploy one thousand troops
currently stationed in germany to
romania another two thousand troops will
be dispatched from the u.s most to
poland and some to germany none will be
placed directly in ukraine
it's all meant to send a message that
the west isn't backing down
problem is neither is russia russia's
security concerns are mostly bluff and
bluster but russia's desire to protect
and preserve a sphere of influence isn't
integral to its self-image as a country
and also putin's uh geopolitical legacy
a spanish newspaper obtained the written
responses to vladimir putin's security
demands in them the u.s and nato offered
to negotiate new disarmament treaties if
russia de-escalates in the region
there are no concessions on putin's
insistence that nato claw back from
eastern europe and bar new member states
like ukraine a failure of the west
in ukraine
will send a message across the globe
that the west is incapable of defending
its core principles and thus incapable
of defending itself
during a wednesday phone call british
prime minister boris johnson warned
putin that an invasion would be a tragic
miscalculation
the next move is russia's to make the
biden administration insists the new
troop deployment is consistent with what
the u.s has already told russia it's
about combat readiness and about
reassuring nervous nato allies who've
seemed uncertain about confronting the
russian threat
donna jackson prosco in washington
thanks gearing up for the winter games
in beijing coming up the celebrations
and the controversies in china
[Music]
let's welcome our canadian team flag
bearers
and shal amela
those two canadian athletes are getting
a special honor they will carry the flag
at friday's opening ceremony of the
winter olympics women's hockey captain
marie philippe poulet and speed skating
star star charles amelan will share the
honor she is a two-time olympic champion
and he has won five medals including
three gold
the upcoming games are expected to be
one of the most complicated and
controversial in history not only will
athletes be competing under strict kobit
19 protocols as eric sorenson explains
they'll also be navigating politics
human rights and free speech
the torch relay has begun a sign of the
growing festive spirit before every
olympics
and a big moment for the canadian team
the flag bearers were revealed charles
emelin is a five-time olympian with
three speed skating gold medals and
marie philippe has won gold twice in
hockey i am very happy
it's a lot of pride in that moment it's
something that we look for for four
years and
it's like a little gift that
people gave us friday's opening ceremony
will give the games an upbeat start but
these olympics will arrive with perhaps
less global enthusiasm than ever before
the covid pandemic has imposed severe
restrictions on athletes cutting off
olympic visitors from seeing and showing
off the host country and for many
china's conduct has created a cloud over
the usual joy that precedes the games
in several countries protests have
condemned china from its treatment of
the mostly muslim uyghur population to
its crackdown on pro-democracy activists
in hong kong
china is using the olympics to restore
its image says this advocate to hide its
terrible human rights record this debate
around the human rights record of china
has not gone away at all if anything
it's increasing because of the
restrictions
that have been put on media coverage and
on athletes expressing their own
opinions about things canada joined a
diplomatic boycott of the beijing games
no government officials will be there
the canadian olympic committee just
wants the athletes to compete well we
certainly respect the government's right
to have made that decision but we
believe it's important to be here the
power of sport comes from the bringing
together as opposed to the isolation
emphasizing sport the ioc avoids
political confrontation thanks to our
gracious chinese hosts
once the olympic competition begins
politics often seem to melt away but
images of china's president xi jinping
expected to welcome guests like russia's
vladimir putin will be reminders that
current international tensions are not
far removed from these olympic games
eric sorensen global news toronto
the once coveted free island of tonga is
now in complete lockdown after two port
workers tested positive for the virus
the pacific nation is still recovering
after last month's deadly volcanic
eruption and tsunami officials had
feared foreign aid deliveries might
spread the virus it's not clear how the
two port workers became infected though
authorities say several other people on
the island have also since tested
positive
ahead as a winter storm wallops parts of
the u.s the groundhogs weigh in with
their predictions
take a look at this aborted landing at
london's heathrow airport on monday high
winds buffeted this british airways
plane it bounced it tilted to one side
and its tail actually hit the runway
before it took off again the pilot tried
a second time and did manage to touch
down successfully minutes later at the
time a storm had been battering the uk
with winds of up to 144 kilometers an
hour
in the u.s nearly 100 million americans
are under winter storm warnings tonight
weather alerts are in place in more than
a dozen states from new mexico to maine
the storm system is packing heavy snow
freezing rain and strong winds and it
could last several days there's concern
it could be the biggest storm of the
season storm warnings are also in place
for much of a southern ontario quebec
and atlantic canada
and because it is february 2nd we have
to check in with the authorities on
weather predictions the groundhogs
willie says
it's an early spring oh wow yes early
spring well that's what we like to hear
ontario's wyatt and willie saw no shadow
and predicts spring is just around the
corner that optimism though is not
universal both nova scotia's schuberneke
sam and quebec's fred la marmot
saw their shadows so if you believe them
it's six more weeks of winter and that
gobbler's knob pennsylvania pucks the 20
phil saw his shadow too so i think i'll
go with wyatt and willie
this year's nominees for the rock and
roll hall of fame were announced today
and dolly fans will be happy
dolly parton could soon add the
prestigious honor to her many awards and
accomplishments there are 17 nominees in
total including lionel richie
eminem and rage against the machine
the final list of inductees will be
announced in may
here's some more dolly
we're back in a moment
[Music]
we often showcase the legacy of famous
sports stars musicians and politicians
when they die but there are of course
millions of other people who have led
meaningful lives jeffrey hutchings was
one of those people he was a professor
of evolutionary ecology at dalhousie
university and he died this week at the
age of 63. he was a world-class
scientist a fierce advocate of
protecting science from political
interference and as ross lord reports he
was also a remarkable mentor
if life can be measured by the things
people say about us after we're gone
jeffrey hutching's life was superb i
wouldn't be where i am now if it wasn't
for jeff his guidance and him taking a
risk on me
as a professor at dalhousie university
hutchins was known for educating
students about fisheries entirely from
his head no need for notes or power
points as a fisheries scientist he was
legendary for his integrity and his
dedication he didn't want to be popular
he just wanted the right decision to be
made that was for the best interests of
society for conservation for
sustainability hutching's love of the
sea was instilled during visits to
newfoundland and labrador as a child
it was a newfoundland-based crisis the
collapse of the northern cod fishery
where hutchings first rose to prominence
courageously standing up to the federal
department of fisheries and oceans and
accusing it of mismanagement jeff
hutchings went out on a limb and he
called them out for it he wrote a paper
with two
more senior colleagues the bold move by
someone who was still a graduate student
he
was just honestly one of the most
amazing humans and kind people that i've
ever met
for protege sean godwin the shock of his
mentor dying unexpectedly at age 63 is
still fresh but his spirits are lifted
recalling hutchings character he fought
tirelessly to separate science from
politics an iron curtain is being drawn
by government between science and
society
closed curtains especially those made of
iron make for very dark rooms
and he made a difference for consumers
as the independent science advisor for
the grocery giant loblaw he said that it
was one of the most impactful things he
ever did because
sometimes within hours after he made the
advice blah blah would change its its
seafood lineup
at a time when science is under siege
from the misinformed friends and
colleagues say there's even more reason
to commemorate people like jeffrey
hutchings and in this world we need a
lot more jeff that's for sure
ross lord global news halifax
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this wintry view of the
saskatchewan legislature in regina there
are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]